Hubble has been the most productive
telescope in history but its successor
the James Webb Space Telescope is
expected to surpass it in many ways
looking further back to when the
universe's first stars and galaxies
formed and probing the atmospheres of
planets around other stars for signs of
life
to meet these goals NASA and its
partners are building the biggest most
complex and most expensive science
mission ever attempted in the process
engineers have pushed technology to the
limit lighter and stronger mirrors made
of the metal beryllium coated with gold
for superior reflection of infrared
light heat insulation from a Sun shield
the size of a tennis court and
instruments that must work at a chilly
230 degrees Celsius below freezing and
it's so gigantic that for launch the
entire telescope must fold up to fit
inside the rocket once launched Webb
will set off on a 30 day one million
mile journey to its final orbital
position all the while carefully
unfolding himself first the solar array
unfolds to power the telescope then the
communication dishes move into place
next the Sun shield opens protecting the
delicate instruments from the heat of
the Sun
booms flip over revealing the secondary
mirror and finally the side tiles pop
out to complete the primary mirror
scientists will spend many weeks waiting
for the telescope to cool down while
fine-tuning the position and shape of
each of the 18 tiles in the main mirror
only then after two months in space will
the world's biggest eye in the sky turn
its gaze on the cosmos
you